yves d'amécourt yves d'amécourt bonsoir
alors vous vous n'êtes plus candidats le
15 mars votre adjointe sylvie penchons a
été battu par le candidat de et les
filles de 32 voix au premier tour de
l'élection municipale de sauveterre de
guyenne environ dont vous étiez le maire
les républicains vous souhaitez vous
qu'un nouveau scrutin soit tenu pour
quelles raisons oh c'est très simple
nous sommes un certain nombre d'élus de
toute la france à avoir constaté la
désaffection des bureaux de vote le 15
mars notamment due aux messages
sanitaires du coronavirus le discours du
président de la république le jeudi soir
le discours du premier ministre le
samedi soir qui fait qu'un certain
nombre de personnes sont restées chez
elles les personnes avec une santé
fragile les personnes qui voulaient pas
porter le virus à des membres de leur
famille les personnes qui étaient
confinés dans les maisons de retraite
avec interdiction d'en sortir et donc
nous estimons que le scrutin n'a pas été
conforme à l'article 3 de la
constitution puisque tous les français
n'étaient pas égaux devant les
opérations de vote contrairement à ce
que la loi d'urgence coe vide qui a été
voté par le parlement a dit ensuite ça
veut dire quoi comprennent pas il va
d'amécourt que le scrutin pour vous
n'était pas sincère comme on l'a souvent
dit voilà donc en fait aujourd'hui vous
avez un certain nombre de spécialistes
de la constitution qui remettent en
cause la sincérité du scrutin et depuis
d'ailleurs la loi sur les faits que new
skies a été votée par le parlement à la
majorité actuelle est apparue une
nouvelle notion dans la danse en outre
dans notre arsenal législatif qui est la
sincérité national et nous pensons que
le conseil constitutionnel devrait être
interrogé sur cette sincérité du scrutin
du 15 mars
c'est pour ça qu'un certain nombre de
nos adhérents dans toute la france ont
déposé des questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité avec leurs
protestations plus de 3000 protestation
dans toute la france et donc nous
souhaitons que le conseil d'état puisse
se transmettre ces questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité très
rapidement au conseil constitutionnel
laurent fabius il ya quinze jours a dit
qu'il attendait ces qpc pour que le
conseil constitutionnel puisse se
prononcer sur un certain nombre de
questions et donc il serait intéressant
que cela soit fait et que cela soit fait
avant que le premier ministre ne
l'organisent l'installation des conseils
municipaux alors l'installation des
conseils municipaux justement c'est
l'information de la journée qu'il est
seront installés au plus tard le 28 mai
c'est une décision du coup que vous vous
contestez mais que nous contestons avant
et que nous allons que nous allons
contester dès que le produit aura pris
sa décision
nous ferons un arrêté suspendant un
référé suspension pour suspendre la
décision du premier ministre
en attendant que le conseil
constitutionnel puisse se prononcer sur
sur ces élections du 15 mars
ce sont à peu près 30% de l'électorat
habituel des élections municipales qui
ne sont pas venus voter c'est énorme
les maires sont les élus préférés des
français parce qu'ils sont bien élu
parce que la participation aux élections
municipales
habituellement et est haute et cette
fois ci ça n'a pas été le cas il ya même
des maires comme par exemple le ministre
des comptes publics gérald darmanin qui
a été élu dans sa ville avec 15% des
inscrits s'étaient c'est à dire que
c'est très peu et la légitimité d'un élu
avec 15% des inscrits est très très
basse c'est votre adjointe avait été
gagnante 1 n'avait pas été battu est ce
que vous auriez réagi de la même manière
que j'en sais rien je fais pas de la
fiction mais en tout cas le combat que
nous menons avec tous ces élus de france
d'ailleurs il ya avec nous des gens qui
ont été élus au premier tour et qui
contestent leur propre élection parce
qu'ils estiment que leur légitimité
n'est pas la même qu'avec une élection
normale
le fait d'avoir organisé ce premier tour
pour le gouvernement certains parlent
d'une faute politique
il ya eu effectivement ça a été prouvé
par la suite des victimes
en tout cas cette journée d'élections si
bien dans la campagne que le niveau de
l'organisation le jour même de
l'élection à ce que vous partagez ce
diagnostic de fautes politiques dont
devra répondre le gouvernement moi je
pense que c'est une faute d'avoir en
même temps mais c est la devise de notre
président annoncé que l'on entré dans la
phase 3 de la pandémie est organisée
tout de même les élections municipales
moi j'ai des membres de ma famille qui
habite dans la sarthe qui ont été qui
ont eux qui ont pris le virus du coc vie
de 19 le jour de l'élection c'est le cas
de ma maman qui a qui a eu le
coronavirus qui a 81 ans qui aujourd'hui
est sorti de de cette histoire et elle
est très fière d'être dans notre sortie
mais voilà j'ai quatre ou cinq membres
de ma famille qui ont eu le coït 19 le
jour du vote
si ce premier tour ne devait pas être
annulé ce qui s'entend même quand même
probable le second tour vous le
souhaiteriez pour qu'on parle du 21 juin
de septembre l'association des maires de
france voudrait la deuxième quinzaine de
septembre et vous en fait si vous voulez
dans l'avis du conseil d'état qui avait
été formulée avant l'annulation du
deuxième tour le conseil d'état disait
que si cette élection n'avait pas eu
lieu au mois de juin il faudrait annuler
le premier tour et donc si aujourd'hui
christian jacob et gérard larcher
demande que l'élection ait lieu en juin
c'est bien parce qu'ils craignent que le
premier tour soit annulé et si on annule
le premier tour dans une partie des
communes de france
on aura beaucoup de mal à justifier
qu'on le maintienne dans les autres donc
en fait aujourd'hui on est dans une
espèce de course à l'échalote
nous nous pensons que l'urgence c'est la
crise du corona virus et que les plus
habilités pour s'en occuper ce sont les
maires élus qui ont l'expérience est
donc le plus simple et le plus facile le
plus le plus serein serait d'annuler
tout simplement ces élections est de le
repousser en septembre ou en mars après
la après la pandémie
merci beaucoup yves d'amécourt d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france